>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE DEMOCRATS SAY THEY DESPISE
DONALD TRUMP, THEY SEEM TO MEAN
IT, THEY TELL US THEY WILL DO
ANYTHING TO PREVENT HIM FROM
CONTINUING AS PRESIDENT.
BUT IF THAT IS REALLY TRUE, WHY
ARE THEY WORKING SO HARD TO
SABOTAGE THEIR OWN CHANCES OF
REPLACING HIM?
WHY DEMOCRATS ARE SUDDENLY
SAYING THINGS THAT ALMOST
GUARANTEE TRUMP'S REELECTION AS
PRESIDENT?
AND JUST THE PAST FEW MONTHS,
DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID THINGS THAT
ARE SO OUT OF THE MAINSTREAM
THAT IT IS VERY HARD TO IMAGINE
VOTERS WILL BACK THEM.
JUST LAST NIGHT ON CNN, WATCH
BERNIE SANDERS, THE FRONT
RUNNER, ENDORSED VOTING FOR
FELONS WHO ARE CURRENTLY BEHIND
BARS.
WATCH THIS.
>> IF SOMEBODY COMMITS A SERIOUS
CRIME, SEXUAL ASSAULT, MURDER,
THEY ARE GOING TO BE PUNISHED.
THEY MAY BE IN JAIL FOR TEN
YEARS, 20 YEARS, 50 YEARS, THEIR
WHOLE LIVES.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
COMMIT A SERIOUS CRIME.
BUT I THINK THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS
INHERITED TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
YES, EVEN FOR TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: TERRIBLE PEOPLE.
SO HOW TERRIBLE IS SANDERS
TALKING ABOUT?
CANNIBALS?
CONVICTED SPIES?
HOW ABOUT TERRORISTS WHO KILLED
CHILDREN?
OH, YES, SAID BERNIE SANDERS,
THEY GET THE VOTE, TOO.
UNLIKE THE FIRST OR SECOND
AMENDMENTS, THAT IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS SEEMED TO
AGREE WITH THAT.
>> PEOPLE WHO ARE CONVICTED,
IMPRISON, LIKE THE
BOSTON MARATHON BOMBER, ON DEATH
ROW, PEOPLE COMMITTED          C
ROW, PEOPLE COMMITTED          N
ROW, PEOPLE COMMITTED          I
ROW, PEOPLE COMMITTED          T
ROW, PEOPLE COMMITTED          D
ROW, PEOPLE COMMITTED          O
ROW, PEOPLE COMMITTED          F
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION.
BEST TO DO IT RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE
WHENEVER THE LEFT TELLS YOU THEY
WANT A CONVERSATION ABOUT
SOMETHING, YOU CAN BE CERTAIN
THAT ANY DISSENT ON THAT SUBJECT
WILL BE BANNED A YEAR FROM NOW,
LIKE 2020 QUESTIONING WHETHER
IMPRISONED TERRORISTS SHOULD
VOTE SHOULD WARRANT A TRIP TO
THE HR DEPARTMENT IN A LIFETIME
BAN FROM PAYPAL AND TWITTER.
WHILE WE STILL CAN, CONSIDER THE
STORY OF JOE CARS ARE UZZIAH,
FIRST TO THE UNITED STATES ON
A TOURIST VISA WITH THE REST OF
HIS FAMILY FROM KURDISTAN, ALL
OF THEM PROBABLY CLAIMED ASYLUM
HERE, THEY WERE GIVEN IT.
OVER TIME, THEY COLLECTED MORE
THAN $100,000 IN TAXPAYER
FINANCE COVERAGE BENEFITS.
IN 2012, HE RECEIVED U.S.
CITIZENSHIP, AND LESS THAN A
YEAR LATER, HE MURDERED THREE
PEOPLE AND MAIMED HUNDRED WITH A
PRESSURE COOKER BOMB AT THE
BOSTON MARATHON, NOW HE IS ON
DEATH ROW.
DEMOCRATS SHARE THAT STORY AND
FEEL OUTRAGED, NOT THAT THEY
REPAID OUR GENERATION WITH A
TERROR ATTACK THAT IT MIGHT
BOTHER YOU, BUT IT DOESN'T
BOTHER THEM.
THEY ARE ENRAGED THAT A
CONVICTED TERRORIST MIGHT NOT BE
ALLOWED TO HELP PICK OUR NEXT
PRESIDENT.
THAT IS OUTRAGEOUS, IN THEIR
VIEW, THE KIND OF
INSTITUTIONALIZED BIGOTRY THAT
KURDISTAN A REFUGEES HAVE FACED
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY NEED REPARATIONS, TOO.
THEY DEFINITELY NEED A VOICE.
CONVICTS OF LOUISIANA COME OF
THE 15,000 PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE PARISH, ONE-THIRD OF THEM
ARE INMATES AT THE
MAXIMUM-SECURITY PRISON FARM.
THEY ARE THE SINGLE LARGEST BLOC
OF VOTERS IN THE AREA.
ACCORDING TO BERNIE SANDERS,
THIS IS BAD BECAUSE THEY ARE
BEING DENIED DEMOCRACY.
THAT IS RACIST AND ONCE